we carried out about 18 months of
research for the state National
Geographic drama we had a team of
researchers based in Britain working
internationally there's a huge amount of
material on social media there's a huge
amount of video material posted by the
Islamic state there scarily proficient
and everything we've done in the drama
stands on the shoulders of that research
although the characters are kind of
composites of a number of real people
everything you see in the drama actually
takes place grows out of the research
that we've carried out so although it
goes under the banner of a fictional
drama because the characters are
fictional every event you see depicted
within it really took place I think
we've always felt that in an ideal world
the show would be an entity antidote to
simplistic thought so people could do so
trying at a different understanding a
deeper understanding of what might
motivate young people to travel to Syria
I think part of the problem is there's a
very unsophisticated view of the kind of
guys from this country and elsewhere in
the world who traveled to Syria and
around about 2014-2015 there's a
tendency to just say well they're
clearly all insane joining some kind of
death cult in the drama we show that
people go out for all different types of
reasons and it's not as simple as people
might think that it's a far more complex
situation and hopefully the drama gets
inside in a way the documentaries can't
drama is always engaged with these
difficult forces within society and and
the state is just another example of
that kind of attempt the Islamic state
has been responsible for a number of
appalling atrocities I don't think we do
a service to the families of those
who've suffered or to those who've been
caught up in their bombing outrages and
survived with horrific injuries by
simply suggesting that the people
involved in this organization are insane
it's our job as dramatists to hold a
mirror up to society and to treat with
these sometimes extremely difficult
subjects that are
of current importance and I suppose our
objective here in trying to examine this
this event which needs to be happening
in in our world at the moment is to try
to take a more nuanced view of it to get
a little bit beyond the depiction of
these people as insane or psychotic
because how are we ever going to combat
it if we don't properly understand it
[Music]
[Music]